I will not see it ended on
the account of this... Say it.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
Full House of the Dragon Episode 8 video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get them and careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll just start at the beginning of
the episode and work our way through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs WTF moments
starting with the episode title the lord of the
tides which is a reference to the lord of House
Velyaron and driftmark because in this episode
corlys velaryon's brother vaemond is challenging
for his claim to driftmark he wants to assert
his claim over rhaenyra's son lucerys who corlys
wanted to inherit in rhaenys choice who's clearly
baela that's the whole reason why she took her to
ward with her the past six years the only big
additions that I could detect in the opening
title sequence were the line between rhaenyra and
Daemon to represent their marriage which they did
in last week's episode and the new lines from
her representing the children that they've had
together since then and she's pregnant with
her third child with him in the episode I'll
talk about them in a second so pretty soon she's
gonna have six kids her first child with Daemon is
aegon III who they introduced to viserys the
second child I think is more poignant because
his name is viserys II she names him viserys after
her father viserys who he also got to meet before
he died in this episode the actual opening scene
takes place on driftmark with rhaenys sitting in
for Corliss while he's been fighting down in the
stepstones but they did explain that they won back
the stepsons in the previous conflict remember
they were worried about a big war starting with
Dorne potentially in the triarchy since then they
explained that they've retaken the stepstones but
the triarchy has resurged and then tried to take
back the stepstones from Corlys Velaryon is how he
got injured this is the older version of Baela
we also meet older rhaena later in the episode
remember they're meant to be twins but they style
their hairs differently so it's a little bit
easier to tell them apart on screen did a real
quick blink and you'll miss it Brienne of Tarth
reference when they reference Evenfall that's
actually the seat of house tarth. So eventually
later in the timeline Brienne of Tarth is born
and raised there when vaemond starts arguing
with rainey's about the succession she mentions
no talk of crow which is another Feast for Crow's
reference they literally reference a feast for
crows like someone actually said the words a feast
four crows in a previous episode too obviously
the big conflict in this episode is him really
not liking rhaenyra in the fact that her children
are bastards in his petition with the Iron Throne
the big problem with runera is that even though
she doesn't really care that much about drift
Mark or its Holdings like she doesn't want it for
herself or her family or anything like that she's
not mad with power in that way she's more worried
that calling the legitimacy of her children into
question will further cause questions on her
legitimacy for the Iron Throne so she's really
worried about the Iron Throne when Bayman says
that it's a queen who sits the Iron Throne these
days not a king that's a reference to alicent even
though they transitioned directly to Dragonstone
because technically rhaenyra is the current Heir
and going to become Queen eventually even though
the end of the episode makes you think that
it's going to end very differently there's a
lot of moments like that in this episode where
you think things are a done deal like the best
laid plans and obviously things go completely
off the rails and none of those plans come to
fruition. And on Dragonstone Daemon climbs the
rocks of the mountains into the caves where the
dragons lay their eggs in syrax has laid a new
clutch of dragon eggs which they referenced in
a previous episode when rhaenyra was trying
to betray jakiris to Helaena Targaryen they
actually referenced that later in the episode too
when they're dancing together in front of viserys
like oh they could have been king and queen when
they were all younger rhaenyra said if syrax lays
another clutch of dragon eggs then Aemond would
have his choice of any of those eggs this time
Daemon grabs a new one it looks pretty fresh like
it's still smoking when he prys it out and it's
meant to be another callback to him trying to take
a dragon egg in episode two obviously that was a
big faint though like he hadn't actually gotten
this area pregnant but this time he has three
legitimate very legitimate children with renira
who by the laws of their house in the realm just
in general are entitled to dragon eggs dragon eggs
to their family are more precious than gold it's
like giving a child a nuclear weapon even though
he says that syrax has three new dragon eggs he
only takes one of them that's for their newest
child who's going to be named visenya their oldest
is named aegon III the second is named viserys II
after her father and the third is named visenya
for aegon the conqueror's sister wife vicenya so
the idea is that Daemon wants to put this dragon
egg in vicenya's crib when she's eventually
born also him mentioning that syrax had three
dragon eggs is another reference to Daenerys but
daenerys's dragon eggs actually probably came from
dreamfyre Helaena's Dragon because later in the
timeline there were three dragon eggs that were
stolen from dreamfyre's clutch in physically
dreamfyre resembles Daenerys dragons in the
map table room jacaerys is learning High Valyrian
that sounds like he just started and he's getting
a history lesson from this maester about the path
of aegon the conqueror during the conquest making
first landfall at what eventually became King's
Landing that's what he's referencing when they
talk about him felling the trees what happened was
as the aegon and the Conqueror made landfall in
the area that they just renamed to King's Landing
later after he won the war of Conquest the city
was sort of built up around that place but until
then it was really just a military fort that they
called aegon fort in fact after the high septon
crowned aegon king of Westeros he went and ruled
from the aegon fort for the rest of his life the
actual red key like the big castle that you see
in present day was actually built by maegor much
later in the timeline near the fire you notice
baby Joffrey no longer quite the baby with one of
the servants I think the picture book that he's
reading from is another picture book about aegon
the conqueror when she mentions that she's going
to be deposed that's also a reference to what
happens at the end of the episode with the idea
that alicent thinks that aegon II has been named
air in the greens this is their faction in the
dance of the dragons is basically going to pull a
coup in next week's episode and try to name aegon
II the official King when they arrive back at the
red keep they're greeted by Lord Caswell if you
remember he was the person that greeted rhaenyra
on the stairs when she had just given birth to
baby Joffrey asking her if she needed any help
anything at all just let me know in the future
that was a reference to the eventual coming of
the dance of the dragons like he'll probably
declare for the blacks that's another really
interesting thing in the episode too based on
what color you see people wearing in the episode
that basically lets you know who they're going
to declare for when the battle lines are actually
drawn so for instance rhaenys is wearing black the
entire episode during the episode she basically
declares her support for renero the same is true
for a lot of The Other Side characters too in the
background that don't have a lot of speaking lines
in the episode they also take note that alicent
has swapped in a bunch of symbols of the faith of
the seven for all the Targaryen heraldry she's
also wearing the seven-pointed star around her
neck on a chain the reason for that is because
her family has this long history with the faith
of the seven remember they're from Old Town and
before aegon's Conquest the faith of the seven
was centered in Old Town so for thousands of
years their family was very close to the faith
of the seven itself and she's always believed in
the faith but it sounds like she's become way more
devout in her older age it's also a reference
to what happened with tommen later during the
events of the main show too when the faith of the
seven basically kind of took over Tom and kind of
co-opted him and they replaced a lot of heraldry
around the red keep with symbols of of the faith
itself it's just meant to show you the growing
influence of the faith of the seven in the realm
that'll become a bigger thing during the events
of this show which I'll talk about in future
Seasons because I think some of it won't be paid
off till like Season Two Season three they also
reference during the small council meeting that
a lot of the members of the faith are requesting
more funds from the crown that's going to become
a big problem in the future like they're just kind
of seeding a lot of this faith of the seven plot
in the background now they pay off the reference
about the queen sitting the Iron Throne when
we see alicent sitting at the head of the small
council because of what's happened with viserys
him becoming so infirm when Thailand Lannister
mentions jacarus's Dragon that's Vermax who's
gotten much bigger since the last episode but
he's still relatively small compared to the other
dragons the other members of the small council
also make reference to him being a bastard without
actually coming out and saying it out loud clearly
the members of the small council want to declare
for vaman like they don't want to have anything to
do with rhaenyra's children I'll talk about this
more in a second too because it has a lot to do
with the way that alicent is taking all this and
playing the Game of Thrones so to speak because
it seems that she really does not like playing the
game of Thrones whereas her father Otto Hightower
is really trying to push her around the board so
to speak the way that he pushed her around when
she was younger like why don't you go spend some
more time with viserys when rhaenyra goes to see
her father they show the ancient valyria model
has cobwebs all over it this book is probably
another history book about ancient Valeria just
showing you that it's been a long time since he's
actually worked on his model because his condition
has gotten so much worse he's almost like a living
corpse at this point which is why I was really
surprised that he died at the end of this episode
and not an episode nine like I was expecting like
one more episode out of him he's been kind of like
the Sean Bean of the show so you're just kind of
waiting for him to die like when is it going to
happen because the actual conflict that dance of
the Dragons doesn't really start till his actual
death they use their conversation to set up a
lot of what happens at the end of the episode
too where he confuses alicent with rhaenyra and
just confuses the two different versions of aegon
so alicent thinks that he's really talking about
aegon II when he was actually thinking that he
was talking to rhaenyra about aegon's prophecy of
A Song of Ice and Fire where aegon saw up at the
North they're careful to highlight the fact that
he's got got so much milk of the poppy in his tea
like his quote unquote tea is addling his brain
so to speak but that's because he's in a constant
state of pain like they're very careful to show
you how much pain he experiences just trying to
walk around or even speak to someone is also meant
to be a mirror for alicent with the moon tea later
with the servant girl who's gotten pregnant with
aegon the seconds bastard which is also meant
to be a callback to rhaenyra's Moon Tea in the
earlier episode when the grand maester prepared
the same thing for her and if it wasn't clear
alicent is genuinely sympathetic to her plight
she totally believes her like oh yeah my son
definitely forced himself on this girl poor girl
that's why she gives her that lump of gold in the
moon tea just to let her know oh we're not going
to have you killed but you definitely have to
leave the red keep but isn't it ironic that she's
now facing the same situation that she had been so
upset at rhaenyra for previously aegon II Breaking
All the Rules but because she wants to uphold the
status quo this whole question of the bastards and
who becomes the next king she's kind of forced to
live with it which is why she kicks around aegon
II so much like you're no son of mine you're
such a terrible person it's also a call back
to Cersei and Joffrey with the way that Cersei
loved Joffrey but he was a terrible person and
she had trouble controlling him the big difference
with aegon II is that he clearly wants nothing to
do with being King it's like he's pulling a Jon
Snow here I don't want it him sleeping with the
servant girls and being drunk most of the time
is also right out of the books too like he was
very fond of drink that only got worse when he got
older and he really really loved getting with the
servant girls and I love the irony of the moment
when Helaena walks in asking what happened to
the servant girl that she just had to get rid of
because of the bastard child what happened to her
she was supposed to get the children ready that's
a reference to her legitimate children that she
had with aegon II remember alicent betrothed them
previously and since then she's had three children
with him it's jaeherys, jaehera and maelor maybe
we'll see them in season two they're also meant to
be very young and she makes some jokes about being
married to him later in the episode too after he
makes a bunch of jokes at jakaris about still
being a virgin. Rhaenyra and alicent have their
big reunion scene and they just show you the
things are are still pretty tense between them
even though they cooled off quite a bit there's
just a little acrimonious at this point early
in the episode but it does seem for a brief hot
second that they actually might mend their fences
until the end of the episode when she first walks
in too they're careful to focus the camera on her
scar that's left over from the valyrian dagger
like oh the last time we met as they focus on
the scar the boys go back to the yard and see the
old practice damage all the fun that they used to
get up to they talk about Criston Cole's Morning
Star the one that he's currently fighting with
Aemond practicing with that's the same weapon
that he fought Daemon with during the tourney
at the beginning of the series and obviously all
the children are older in this episode so we have
the much older version of aemond who seems like
now he loves violence and I think that's why he
tells Kristen Cole that he doesn't care about
tourneys because when vaman walks in he perks
up or any time he thinks that a fight is about
to break out he perks up later in the episode
in fact at the dinner table later when they avert
a conflict early on he seems really crestfall and
like oh I was hoping for a fight that's mostly
foreshadowing for what he'll be like during
the actual conflict later I don't think he's a
total madman or anything like that I think that
he just loves violence now like he's become very
twisted in the years since the last episode back
in the godswood rhaenyra and rhaenys betrothed all
their children together although they don't seal
the deal to the actual meeting later like rainey's
declaring it in front of the king is her basically
saying oh yes I agree to all your terms we also
finally see the older version of rhaena in the way
that rhaenys talks about it it sounds like rhaena
stayed on Dragonstone with Daemon because that's
her father so only Bayla has been on driftmark
these past six years as rainey's Ward the fact
she's wearing black here early in the episode is
also meant to foreshadow her eventually declaring
her support for rhaenyra really interesting to
note that rhaenys still thinks that rhaenyra
was responsible for laner's death and when she
denies it in the episode like I had nothing to
do with your son's death she's not lying because
later is still alive we'll see if she ever learns
the truth in the future you can let me know in
the comments if you think that rhaenyra will
eventually tell her no no your son's actually
alive there's always the possibility that laner
Aaron could come back in the future pretending
to be somebody different and just helping them
during the actual battles but the whole idea
is that jakaris is going to marry rhaena and
lucerys will marry Baela so that rhaenys will get
all the things that she originally wanted viserys
continues to confuse rhaenyra with alicent further
setting up the confusion at the end of the episode
the other interesting moment here too is rhaenyra
basically telling viserys that she doesn't want
the Iron Throne like I'm tired of all the drama
she pulls a Jon Snow I don't want it this episode
was full of people saying that they did not want
the Iron Throne also the smoke coming from the
model of ancient valyria as he's being treated for
his wounds in the Bell tolling is foreshadowing
for his death like they would light the smoke and
ring the bell to mark his passing in the naming of
the new King which it sounds like will happen
in next week's episode also love the way they
transitioned to the overhead shot of the iron
throne in what's happening because of the whole
Battle of the succession that's happening on the
show right now there's so many metaphors in this
shot too like there's so much that you could take
out of this particular scene the way that they
filmed it during the petition vaman May takes all
these references to the histories of both House
Targaryen and house velaryon I talked a lot about
those histories in my previous videos so I'll link
those Below in the description he also keeps
talking about Bloodlines and the purity of his
blood for those of you wondering why Daemon was
laughing during the funeral scene in the previous
episode that's also the reason why he was laughing
because during vaman's speech a lot of what he was
saying was about being pure of blood so Daemon
was laughing about him trying to secretly knock
rhaenyra's children being bastards and now he's
just doing it in a much more open way when he says
he could cut his veins and show them his blood
that's obviously foreshadowing for Daemon doing
exactly that ending the matter and when viserys
walks in to preside over the meeting not on the
Milk of the poppy like clear of mind you need
to take note of the way that alicent reacts to
a lot of this because she seems so worried about
what's going to happen to him and the pain that
he's in if he didn't realize alicent was also the
final caretaker for King jaeherys before visares
so during his final days alicent watched over King
jaeherys the same way that she's is watching over
King viserys so watching him waste away is really
painful for her having to relive a lot of the
memories of what it was like watching King jiharis
waste away so they do want you to sympathize with
a lot of her wanting to give him that milk of
the poppy even though it does addle his brain
and cause a lot of confusion in the worst possible
way at the end of the episode The Crown falling
off his head and Daemon picking it up is more of
a callback to previous episodes with him wanting
the throne for himself but he's clearly very sad
about what's happened to his brother rhaenys'
speech about the succession over driftmark is
her basically agreeing to all of rhaenyra's
terms like oh and by the way they're all going to
get married when you look at everybody's reactions
to a lot of this before things go off the rails
aegon II smiles a little bit that's because he
feels like things are settled and he doesn't have
to worry about becoming King likes oh thank god it
doesn't have to be me obviously he spoke too soon
because it sounds like they're going to force him
to put the crown on in next week's episode drag
him kicking and screaming to the Iron Throne love
the way that daemon eggs him on and the way they
pay off this moment about taking his tongue oh he
can keep his tongue and like I said you look at
eamon's reaction he seems enthralled by the sight
of all this violence like oh this is amazing
let's do more of this big big red flags coming
from aemond in this episode the scene of both of
the women in frame of the Iron Throne the blacks
versus The Greens the succession all reference
to the coming dance the dragons and the conflict
starting in next week's episode then the scene
of rhaenys watching The Silent sisters prepare
vaemond's body I think it's just a way to honor
him and honor all the dead people that she's known
like she references all the dead people she's lost
to the maester then I love this dinner scene so
when viserys walks in sitting between the women
even though it starts kind of tense for a while
in the episode you think like it all might be
okay viserys is getting everything that he wanted
everybody is making nice making peace with each
other the cane that he's using there looks like
it has a little dragon head on it and then if
things actually went off the rails it was really
mostly the kid's fault like fighting the way
that you would expect kids to fight aegon making
fun of jacares for being a virgin then Helaena
making fun of aegon for being a bad husband but
near analysis seemed like they temporarily set
aside their differences and it almost works like
for a little while rhaenyra is planning on coming
back and spending time with her like they used to
when they were younger when they were best friends
it even sounds like they were almost leveraged at
one point too when she says she's going to return
to the red keep on Dragon back that's obviously
herd thinking that she's going to just come
back really fast on her own but really it's a
reference to her coming to the red keep on Dragon
back with fire like I will come back and it will
be War they make another pink dread joke when
they serve the pig to aemond he makes another
strong boy's joke to jakaris and luceris inside
No 2 Helaena's comments when she says beware the
Beast beneath the boards that's not a dragon dream
because like when she was younger she spoke all
in Prophecy she still has Dragon dreams but the
Beast beneath the boars is just a reference to
aegon sleeping with all the servants like beware
of aegon trying to sleep with you but the Beast
beneath the boards is literally like the beast
within aegon's pants when Daemon diffuses the
tension at the end of the episode before the kids
break into all-out fight and you see this seen
between him and Eamonn that's also a reference
to them later in the godswood but that won't
happen until like season three maybe so I'll just
wait to talk about that till later but eventually
they will go at each other on Dragon back mysaria
comes back into the story remember she's kind of
like a version of Varys she has little birds and
it turns out the woman who informed alicent about
what happened with aegon in his bastard and the
servant girl is working for messeria so when she
says oh it sounds like things were busy at the
red keep today it's just to let you know that
missary knows everything that's been going on this
entire time she'll have much more influence on the
actual plot in future Seasons then at the end of
the episode obviously he speaks to alicent about
aegon's prophecy about the long night believing
that she's rhaenyra and she being someone who is
hardcore about duty and honor that's why she got
so pissed off at rhaenyra when they were younger
believes that he's forcing her to unite The Realm
by naming aegon II to the iron throne and she
thinks that she's going to honor his wishes like
do right by him by completing that so that's what
she means when she says I understand what you mean
and I will do it she thinks that she's honoring
his memory doing the right thing when really he
was talking about aegon the conqueror and she
just confused it thinking that he was talking
about aegon II also love the way they end this
shot on the valyrian dagger like ooh this is not
going to end well which is also a callback to the
conflict in episode 7 with her attacking rhaenyra
with the Valyrian dagger then he dies the king is
dead along live the king his dying last words are
my love and that's him greeting his original wife
aemma remember he confused alicent for aemma
in last week's episode too she was the love of
his life so it's like he's greeting her seeing
her again in death it was a great episode if
you spotted any other Easter eggs or references
in the episode that I didn't talk about in the
video just write down below in the comments in
my episode 9 trailer video we'll post next so
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that but basically this is the actual
start of the real dance of the Dragons everyone
click here for that episode 9 trailer video I'll
update the link as soon as I post that and click
here for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!